there's nothing unusual about watching a
major corporation fumble around
hilariously in an increasingly desperate
and self-defeating effort to handle a PR
crisis of their own making we've
witnessed scenes of this sort many times
in the past but what makes the current
drama with Bud Light so unique and
perhaps really unprecedented in recent
times is that in this case the
corporation is clumsily flailing around
in the hopes of appeasing conservatives
we are not the group that these
companies are usually trying to impress
it's not our outrage that they are
normally responding to but Bud light's
decision to put out a Dylan Mulvaney
celebratory can promoting transgenderism
and the desecration and appropriation of
Womanhood has become a Tipping Point and
things are changing there's there's real
momentum behind the Bud Light boycott
unlike any other attempted conservative
boycott in memory and that momentum is
only growing even as Bud Light tries to
stymie it by doing anything except the
one thing that could bring this all to
an end which is to explicitly apologize
for pushing gender ideology they haven't
done that yet they're not ready to do
that yet so instead they tried to get
around the issue on Friday with a
statement from Brendan Whitworth who's
the CEO of Anheuser-Busch and the
statement is remarkable in that it goes
on for a long time but says absolutely
nothing at all it reminds me of every
essay I wrote in high school or every
Kamala Harris speech Wentworth quote as
the CEO of a company founded in
America's Heartland more than 165 years
ago I am responsible for ensuring every
consumer feels proud of the beer we Brew
we're honored to be a part of the fabric
of this country Anheuser-Busch employs
more than 18 000 people and our
independent Distributors employ an
additional 47 000 valued colleagues we
have of Partners millions of fans and a
proud history supporting our communities
military First Responders sports fans
and hard-working Americans everywhere we
never intended to be part of a
discussion that divides people we are in
the business of bringing people together
over a beer my time serving this country
taught me the importance of
accountability and the values upon which
America was founded Freedom hard work
and respect for one another as CEO of
Anheuser-Busch I am focused on building
and protecting a remarkable history and
Heritage I care deeply about this
country this company Our Brands and our
partners I spend much of my time
traveling across America listening to
and learning from our customers
Distributors and others moving forward I
will continue to work tirelessly to
bring great beers to Consumers across
our nation
that was the same on second thought
maybe he is saying something significant
here because he said that um
he's going to work to bring great beers
to Consumers which means that that must
be him announcing that he's quitting the
company
then going to work for a beer
distributor that actually makes great
beers because if you want to you know
bring great beers to Consumers then you
can't work for Anheuser-Busch but if
that's not what he means then this
statement doesn't say anything except
that Anheuser-Busch is scared and
they're panicking but they have no idea
what to do about it in fact the
statement is a it's a it's a master
class in self-sabotage so they shot
themselves in the foot and then they
reloaded and shot themselves in the
other foot because by refusing to
directly apologize to their customer
base they've done nothing to quell the
controversy or stop the boycott but by
issuing the statement in the first place
and by admitting at the very least that
transgenderism the transgenderism
conversation divides people even though
they didn't say transgenderism but
that's what they're talking about by by
referring to it as divisive
they also managed to piss off the left
so it's a statement that appeases no one
and makes them look worse to everyone
they had they had a few possible options
for dealing with this PR crisis that
they created for themselves none of them
are great you know you never have a
great option when you're in the middle
of a PR thing but uh but some were
better than others and they surveyed all
of the options and decided to choose the
worst possible one the one with the
biggest downside but no upside to offset
but just brilliant stuff later on the
same day they decided to take a somewhat
different approach without addressing
the controversy at all Budweiser put out
an ad which was meant to Pander to the
customer base that they have alienated
watch
foreign
[Music]
about a beer
rooted in the heart of America
found in a community
where a handshake is a sure contract
brood for those who found opportunity in
Challenge and Hope
in tomorrow
raised by Generations willing
willing sip share
risk
remember
this is a story
bigger than beer
this is the story of the American Spirit
[Music]
hmm
let me tell you a story about a beer
brewed for those who amputate their own
genitals
that would have been a more honest
script instead they went with the old
school pitch to the working class
conservatives hoping that we forget that
their vice president is on the record
saying she doesn't want to appeal to
that demographic anymore I mean they're
throwing it they even had it they had a
911 reference in that they're just
throwing everything against the wall but
uh you know it's it's not gonna it's uh
it's it's not going to make us lose
focus here we haven't forgotten that we
won't
so the boycott is still on
the only thing that brings this to an
end
is a groveling apology that's the only
way this ends or else it ends with Bud
Light simply deciding to absorb the
damage and deal with the financial
repercussions either result is
acceptable to me because they both would
achieve the end goal of punishing
corporate wokism claiming a scalp
and making an example out of somebody
which is which is the point here
as for the financial damage there's no
way to be sure how much is being
inflicted on the company at this point
um you know we'll have clearer picture
of that when the quarterly earnings
reports and all that stuff start starts
coming out right now all we have um are
anecdotes and the anecdotal evidence
makes a pretty compelling case that the
boycott is making a serious Dent the New
York Post published an article
interviewing industry analysts who admit
that this boycott quote has legs Justin
Kendall who's the editor of a beer
industry trade publication brewbound
said that from what he's seen the
anti-bud light movement has gone from
social media and it's made its way into
the mainstream you know those remark
reports that have come in from all over
the country of bars and restaurants that
are refusing to serve Bud Light and
other ones that will still serve it but
they're not able to sell it one of the
most telling signs is a cell phone video
uh which was captured from a concert
where the country artist Riley green was
performing and he he changed the lyrics
in one of his songs the song usually
contains the line I wish coolers never
run out of cold Bud Light but as his own
protest against the beer brand he
changed it to say I wish coolers never
run out of cold Coors Light and listen
to the audience's reaction to that here
it is
oh
I wish I was in the cars
you don't understand
[Music]
because that's that's a very convincing
sign that boycott Bud Light is not just
a Twitter phenomenon but the most
important sign is the behavior of the
company itself the statement they put
out the ad you know none of that says
much but it does say one thing which is
that the company is worried
yet they're they're getting an assist
you know they're worried
the backs against the uh the the wall
here a little bit but they are getting
an assist from what some may consider an
unexpected Source though if you've been
paying attention to politics for longer
than say 30 minutes you would very much
expect it the Republican establishment
is beginning to circle the wagons around
Anheuser-Busch as the daily as The Daily
Beast reports quote the national
Republican Congressional committee
quietly deleted a fundraising page on
Saturday that took aim at one of its
largest donors the parent company of Bud
Light Anheuser-Busch the nrcc's
backpedaling follows conservative calls
for a boycott of the beer company that
it part after it partnered with
transgender Tick Tock personality Dylan
Mulvaney on Saturday morning the
powerful committee that provides support
to Republican Congressional campaigns
blasted out a tweet calling for
supporters to donate to the nrcc and in
exchange be given a custom drink koozie
thanks to Dylan Mulvaney we can all
finally admit that Bud Light tastes like
water the nrcc said in a sense deleted
tweet that The Daily Beast reviewed and
can be seen in the article with our new
Koozies you can make sure that no one
confuses Bud Light with real beer ever
again but shortly after it was posted
around 9 30 a.m the Tweet was taken down
later on Saturday afternoon the
corresponding fundraising page was also
mixed the decision to reverse courses
almost certainly a reaction to the
reality that the parent company behind
Bud Light is a major donor to the group
now I would normally trust The Daily
Beast speculations about such matters
but in this case they appear to be
exactly correct in fact Donald Trump Jr
has made this argument explicitly on his
podcast a couple of days ago Trump
called for conservatives to quote leave
the company alone
because uh they donate to Republicans
that was his reasoning listen
this is one like we're dunking on them
now but when you actually look into it
they'd be one of the more
companies in America so they've been put
on notice I'm leaving them alone I think
you should probably do the same and we
looked into the political giving and
lobbying history of Anheuser-Busch and
guess what
they actually support Republicans in in
woke Corporate America
Anheuser-Busch supports Republicans last
cycle their employees and their Pac gave
about 60 percent to Republicans and 40
percent of Democrats that's literally
almost unheard of in Corporate America
so we should note that Caitlyn Jenner
who was apparently hanging out at
Mar-A-Lago this weekend also came out in
defense of Bud Light for the same
reasons that Don Jr articulated though
Jenner apparently deleted his Pro Bud
Light tweet after I called him out for
it still it's clear that there is a
powerful contingent within the
Republican party that wants us to stand
down for the sake of protecting all of
that sweet sweet donor cash
but that's not going to happen
and and I will explain why
okay first of all
I am well aware that Anheuser-Busch
donates to Republicans and has
Republican Executives and a largely
conservative customer base that's
exactly why we should boycott them okay
it makes their endorsement of gender
ideology all the more outrageous
and it makes them all the more
vulnerable to our pushback against that
marketing decision
as I tried to explain a couple weeks ago
before the Bud Light boycott began in
Earnest if we want to fight back against
corporate wokism we have to be strategic
and intelligent in choosing our targets
okay Nike has partnered with Mulvaney
too you know might Nike had and we could
say in an even more egregious kind of
way Nike sent women's clothing to
Mulvaney including a sports bra and had
this man model it uh which which is
which is even more as I said egregious
and then plenty of cosmetic brands and
women fashion women's fashion brands
have done
similar but we aren't trying to organize
a boycott against those companies why is
that because we have very little power
over them okay you want if you're going
to try something like this you have to
be able to see the win there has to be a
win at the end of it in 2022 84 of
Nike's political donations went to
Democrats in 2020 it was nearly 90
percent so this is a left-wing company
run by left-wing people
and Catering to a customer base that
does not primarily consist of
working-class conservative middle-aged
white men
like Bud Light okay it's not um it's not
plumbers from Idaho or truck drivers
from Wisconsin who are going out to buy
200 Nike shoes
so it's it's not going to be very
effective to organize a boycott against
the company that doesn't care what we
think and doesn't need our business
how is that supposed to work exactly so
all these conservatives and it's not
just the the those in the establishment
and high-ranking Republicans and so on
I've seen this on on Twitter and on
social media
plenty of conservatives saying what's
the point of this I mean Nike this
company that company they're all woke
what do you what do you think you're
going to do about Nike
Bud Light on the other hand does need
our business
and so they do or should care what we
think
this gives us power that we can either
choose to actually use for a change or
we can sit back quietly and absorb the
insult like we always do and to that
second option I say hell no
we have power in this case let's
actually use it I know that that concept
is like mind-boggling to a lot of
Republicans
but when you have power you should use
it
this is what the GOP establishment and
its donor class don't understand
okay we are sick and tired of this we
are sick and tired of watching as our
culture is claimed piece by piece by
Madness and degeneracy we are not okay
with it we are Furious about it in fact
and we aren't following your lead in the
fight against it because you people
aren't interested in fighting against it
well we're not going to sit around and
and wait for you to execute your master
plan to win back the culture you have no
such plan
you're satisfied to let the culture
crumble and Decay as long as you can
have a hand in ruling over the rubble
and that's how we got to this point in
the first place where transgenderism is
the sort of thing that even Bud Light
feels it needs to promote
that's how the total denial of
biological reality became mainstream and
seized hold of our society it happened
because the conservative quote unquote
leadership
tasked with defending our country
against evils like gender ideology
abdicated their responsibility
they gave up without putting up even the
semblance of a struggle
they left it to the rest of us to fight
this battle and so and so we are
you're asleep we're taking the wheel
it's that simple
and we don't care about Republican
donors
okay the Republican donors are as
worthless as the Republicans they donate
to so I don't give a damn about them
and you could scoff all you want right
but this boycott matters it does
it matters because it's obviously not
just about one beer company it's about
making a statement it's about achieving
a victory for truth and Sanity it's
about doing the things that you people
won't do
so step aside and let us handle it
okay we'll we'll do everything you'll do
nothing and then later on when we get
the win you can run campaign ads
pretending that you did something as
always and that's fine
I don't even care about that I just want
the win
that's all that matters
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]